قال رضا بلحاج القيادي في جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه المعارضه في تونس ان قوات امنيه
اقتحمت منزل عصام الشاب الامين العام
للحزب الجمهوري المعارض واعتقلته وقال
نجيب الشاب رئيس جبهه الخلاص وشقيق عصام
الشاب ان مجموعه من عشرين عنصرا امنيا
اعترضوا شقيقه عصام عندما كان برفقه زوجته
في الشارع واعتقلوه بعد تفتيش منزله ودانت
حركه النهضه اعتقال الشاب واعتبرته اعتداء
جديدا على احد رموز المعارضه لما وصفته
بالانقلاب الغاشم ياتي اعتقال الشاب ضمن
سلسله اعتقالات تشنها السلطات التونسيه
على معارضين لاجراءات الرئيس قيس سعيد
شملت سياسيين واعلاميين ورجال اعمال وقضى
ومحامين ويعد الشاب بارفع سياسيا من حيث
الصفه الحزبيه يعتقل حتى الان كما افادت
مصادر الحقوقيه تونسيه باعتقال القياديه
في الخلاص المعارضه شيماء عيسى
وقال الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد ان هناك
حملات وصفها بالمسعوره من اشخاص قال انهم
ماجورون من الخارج لضرب الدوله التونسيه
على حد تعبيره اضاف سعيد انه يخوض حربه
تحرير وطني دعيا القضاء الى القيام بدوره
وتطبيق القانون على الجميع
ويحبوا يرجعوا للشعب كما الادويه بالضبط
مده صلاحيتها ولا بعض الاغذيه التي انتهت
مده السلوقيتها رومنتات ايضا مده سلوحيتهم
ولذلك تراهم يتخبطوا وثم
الحملات المسعوره امتاع الناس الماجورين
ورمناء
للخارج ولجهات المشبوهه لضرب الدوله
التونسيه
وقال الاتحاد الاوروبي انه يتابع بقلق
التطورات الاخيره في تونس التي اعتبرها
جاره قريبه جدا تربطه معها شراكه عميقه
واستراتيجيه اضاف في بيان ان تونس تمر
بلحظه حساسه ويامل الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
تتمكن السلطات التونسيه من العثور على
الحلول المناسبه للعديد من التحديات
الحاليه والمستقبليه التي تواجهها البلاد